everyone first speaker for the afternoon
session Sanjeev Arora he'll tell us
about semantic coding - okay so I'll so
this is joint work in a few papers with
you Anjali you can julienne finger ma
non there is this key to some of the
papers I would subsets of them I
mentioned that later
okay so semantics let me start by the
with this example so which pair of
senses
out of these five are more similar which
I go rules this jungle look Louis flow
from the bottle you can't complain about
for earthquake the line hunting of
forest is the fun workshop isn't it what
is for 1 in 4 correct yeah
so ok now nowadays that's they have no
words in common
right no words in common but you knew
that they were similar okay so I'll set
up this area using some I call history
but it's really recent history but
background really so semantic hashing
this paper had a very big conceptual
impact on me when I saw it like five
years ago something by Hinton said I
couldn't go Hinton is of course the
leader of the recent wave of deep
learning work and this paper made two
points in my opinion and some of the
points I only understood in retrospect
what they were saying
so the first main point was and this
relates to the discussion this morning
in some of the talks approaches like
nearest-neighbor
which are very popular in theory assume
that meaning of whatever object you're
looking at resides in a metric problem
okay points and similarity equals small
L sub P distance and this is false in
most settings including text okay as we
saw in the previous example
and the second point what is this and
the second point I made was that in most
of these settings meaning corresponds to
latent structure and which the proposed
can be recovered in many settings using
Hinton's restricted Boltzmann machine
which is something like a simple one
layer neural net and they showed
experimentally that it beats for many
settings nearest neighbor with locality
sensitive hashing so what is the RPM for
this talk you won't need it too much
won't need the details somebody but I
want to show you roughly what it's like
so it has its it's a it's a simple Bayes
net or graphical model so there's
visible units where you will input the
beta and there's hidden units and the
distribution of hidden and visible units
is a Joint Distribution expressed using
this this kind of energy function which
is like an easing model but it's
bipartite okay so that all the
interactions are entirely between here
and here sorry between this and this not
not no interactions within so it's some
kind of an easing model and so it
defines a joint distribution and then
given some value for your data X there's
a most likely value for the hash age and
that's the semantics hash okay so that
was the main message of this paper and
there show that that actually is a much
better way to recover latent structure
okay so for instance if you input those
two sentences that what I said you know
you would find that the the the latent
the sorry the hidden hash will be
actually similar for those two related
sentences in structure means means that
hash what is latent structure good yeah
so as I said there's only background
yeah I'm getting there okay absolutely
that's the point of the phone
the indicator vectors so what you see
here is for text yeah it's just which
words I knit and their frequency yeah
the bag of words okay
and we agreed that those two sentences
that no words in common so those vectors
will not forgive it yes it's a
completely different functional form
it's this easing model I mean you never
saw this in locality-sensitive hashing
it's some easing model so the hidden
units you can think of it you know this
is the data this is the hash and there's
some computation that map's data to hash
right in that sense there is no no magic
the magic if any is this funny form and
and that this funny form recovers some
latent structure okay so so you train
this it's so unlike in less search and
so on where the hash doesn't depend on
the data set this hash is trained
actually maybe that's the third main
point with this hash is trained using
Veda
so you use a lot of X's you use it to
train this easing model and you know
find this best fit and then that's your
hash for the for the remaining points so
that's actually a third mean pointer to
measure okay so yeah what is this late
instructor so exactly I'm just telling
you you know what I saw five years ago
and it's like yeah completely a new
world right what the heck is going on
okay
why not so so I've understood now for a
couple years what's going on but with my
sonora cesky we said okay maybe we can
make the same point using a simpler
model not an RBM and turns out you can
illustrate this form at this exact
phenomenon that you know the there's no
latency there's no visible structure but
there's a latent structure using a
simple mixture model not just an RBM but
I won't give that example here but you
know it's almost an exercise you can you
can do that using simple mixture model
okay so next piece of history boredom
innings
so these have been popular in
information retrieval in NLP natural
language processing since at least 1990
its core where it was called latent
semantic analysis and what it does is it
represents them each word with a vector
and such that human judgments about
which words are similar like lion and
tiger are similar correspond to
similarity between the vectors okay back
there in a product so these are called
worden bearings and so they were used to
capture similarity avoids so like it's
used information retrieval like if
there's a search query or web search
query
you know when the query you know like if
there's a query about line you might
want to extend to Tigers so so those
towards a very similar so you may have
you may use these word embeddings to
figure out which was it and recently so
this is a this this was a paper that
caused a lot of attention that got a lot
of attention by Michelob arugula team
which showed that using word embeddings
or special type of word embedding you
can solve word analogy tasks using
linear algebra so so what an idea I mean
you know managed to woman as king is to
and whoops I also have the answer here
right okay
sorry okay so so how do you solve it by
linear algebra so you take the word
embeddings which I haven't shown you how
to compute yet but I will
so you take the word marry which are
vectors and now you take the difference
between the vector for the man and woman
so that difference and now you take the
vector for King and you look for the
word so again this should have appeared
now with it so you look for the word
says that that difference is as close to
this difference as possible and among
all dictionary words like the 100,000
words in the English dictionary Queen
happens to be the one the best one okay
so they showed that using their
embeddings you could solve analogies by
this simple linear algebra okay so yeah
and that's objective function so so
that's that's another piece of history
so now I'll get to your question what is
meaning anyway
what is meaning what is this Layton
structure and how can mathematics
capture it and the goal will be that
we're trying to theory we'll have
presently clean models and cool the
correct albums that's what we want to
build towards and for most of the talk
I'll restrict attention to text although
recent work suggests that similar ideas
apply to collaborate filtering like you
know recommending movies or music to
somebody based on what they like and
vision recognizing objects and so on
okay so what is meaning okay and just in
the text setting so here's a test think
of a word that co-occurs with cow
drink babies and calcium milk okay what
you just saw was an example of what's
called so the linguists thought about
this a lot you know what is meaning and
so on and just by introspection they
realized okay like wild lion and tiger
similar right just similar because you
know they occur within similar context
with other words so that's called the
distribution hypothesis the meaning is
it comes from linguistics that a meaning
of a word is determined by the words of
co-workers with okay so it's a kind of a
social network notion of who you are
right you are who your friends are right
so who you hang out with so a meaning of
a word is determined by words it
kokuritsu okay so it's a distributional
notion of meaning and somehow if you
have a similar distribution of words
around you then you are similar okay so
two words that have a similar
distribution or the water on them okay
so this is somewhat imperfect capturing
of meaning okay and it's known that this
is not the ultimate definitional meaning
you there are things that violate this
but it's still a pretty good definition
okay so this definition already suggests
that the following is an way to capture
the meaning of a word namely just give
me the Corcoran's probabilities of all
other words around this world okay so
look at a large corpus like Wikipedia
and around this word
look at how often there's some other
word see occur
I say within distance fight in the
corpus so that's some empirical
distribution of other words around it
and that distribution captures the
meaning of the word okay so that's the
high dimensional word embedding what's
the dimension of this there are a
hundred thousand words in the dictionary
and the dimension of this vector is
hundred thousand five words way yeah in
so every time this word occurs what are
the words okay and you keep track of
those Corcoran's probabilities empirical
call control okay so so that's a that's
a simple word embedding turns out so
church enhance again these are linguists
they suggested a better measure than
Corcoran's which is called PMI
point-wise mutual information
okay this occurred in thing you must
talk like yesterday in the in the quick
talk section so what is it
it's log of some quantity and what is
the quantity the joint probability
divided by the product of the marginal
probabilities the probability the word
and the probability of the other words
see so this is some this ratio is some
kind of a correlation measure right so
WNC occurs sort of uncorrelated then the
joint probably would be the product of
the marginals and that ratio is one and
the log is zero okay so for uncorrelated
words the log is this this measure is 0
and for correlated words where you know
conditional and W of C occurs much more
than you would expect from just the
product probability then that number is
more than 1 in the log is something
substantial ok so this measure captures
it's a measure of correlation but it's a
little log scale ok and you can sort of
see where this is going ok remember I
started with the Hinton model which had
an exponential and this has a log ok is
the the I think those are related ok so
now even better so this is still a
hundred thousand dimensional vector okay
so for W you have all these hundred
thousand dimensional PMI measures for
all the other words and even better
version of this is a dimension reduced
version of the above of the above to
you can do it with via singular value
decomposition or neural nets etc okay so
those are low dimensional worden
bearings something like 300 dimensions
seems to be good okay 100 200 300 yeah
symmetric you you can also consider
asymmetric versions this is a very big
area which I'm not going into yeah so
these are this like very simple ideas
but these are already very powerful so
yeah this is the main point that there's
a law here okay and that log I think is
related to the exponential I think
there's really something going on with
meaning that involves the log okay
history see neural language models this
is also from the last 15 years or so
they start with the paper of been Benjy
and Duchamp and Cobain Weston so this is
again an example of you know you're
trying to understand the meaning of
language right so you're trying to do
things with it natural language
processing and the hypothesis is it's
related to the distribution hypothesis
that a neural net has understood
language if it can predict given the
last few words or last ten words
whatever the next word what does that
mean it just has a good so it the neural
net given the last ten words generates
some distribution on words and in the
empirical word that actually occurs
there happens to have high probability
okay so that's the training so yeah you
how do you train a recurrent neural net
so it gets positive feedback if the
actual next word at high probability and
negative feedback otherwise so neural
net as it goes along the text has a sort
of probability distribution on what word
it expects to see next and if it's guess
is correct then it gets positive
feedback and otherwise negative okay
that's roughly the idea that's the way
you train it and Michael overall had a
simple functional form to break the word
from the five surrounding words which is
the following it's a is a falling
expression that you have a vector for
each word and the probability of the
word W given W 1 to W 5 is proportional
to exponential
of the inner product of V W with the
average factor of the last five words
okay it's a kind of funny functional
form firstly there's an exponential
secondly it's saying something like the
probability of the next word is related
to the average vector of the last five
words in W is the okay so then so the so
the neural net has some parameters and
these are the parameters of the neural
net V W a vector so the neural net is
storing a vector for every word in the
dictionary and it's training those those
are its parameters and it's trying to
train the V W so that this distribution
actually describes very well what's
happening so these are the parameters of
new orlean sorry
300 that's good yeah you can make it 710
you know it's this it captures slightly
different things v was just something I
picked up the variance of this which
actually use that too yeah this is only
one of many many things you can try yeah
other tricks that were used like biasing
sampling we'll get to the biasing we'll
get the biasing that's actually very
important then yeah people actually
didn't understand I have a good nice
explanation any other questions
okay all right so then you know people
that said okay you can understand you
can have word embeddings you can also
create sentence and paragraph embeddings
capture the meaning of the paragraph and
what do you do with the once you capture
the meaning of the paragraph you try to
understand you know with the paragraph
which is a yelp review is there a
positive yelp review a negative variable
you know things like that so so you can
do you can use similar ideas to create
sentence and paragraph embeddings and
one paper was closer I'll skip thought
and it's these things are useful for
other NLP tasks like spotting paraphrase
you know are these similar paragraphs or
not you know or sentiment analysis is a
positive yelp review or negative Y or
given the review predict what is it a
five-star review or a four-star review
or three so let me say it again so the
newer Lynette had some parameters I
every neuron ahead parameters the
parameters of this neural net happened
to be a vector for every word 300
national vector where we work so it's
like 30 million parameters something
which are going to Train and the corpus
has like size a few billion and you're
going to train this model so that given
you know it's this distribution fits
very well roughly that's what I do
your questions
all right so rest of the talk is we're
going to develop they're the ones that
explain what the instructors been
captured by such semantic coding and
hashing and you'll see it's a surprising
confluence of new and old methods which
will consider this think like our names
our BMS PMI abased embedding script etc
some of these came from other fields
like here my embeddings came from NLP
and information retrieval okay and the
idea in this is what's the latent
structure so so there's some process
going on in the head of the writer right
imagine there's a simple single person
writing Wikipedia so there's some
semantic process going on and and then
that semantic process leads to some
words appearing right and so there must
be some connection between this
underlying semantic process and the
words that are being emitted and so
we've come up with a model for that okay
a very simple model which will remind
you of the RPM and then we'll see that
that model implies some properties of
this empirical distribution and they'll
turn turn out to fit reasonably well
then pretty good solutions okay
so so let me clarify or sharpen that
question by this question why do
low-dimensional word vectors exist okay
so like this neural net right why does
it have 300 mention vectors that
empirically describe that distribution
right so right so I already said this
there was a church in Hanks embedding
and you are fitting to PMI right but
yeah the vector is all you know rows and
columns of words so that's a hundred
thousand five hundred thousand matrix
and W w prime entry is this PMI measure
it's nonlinear measure of co-occurrence
correlation and and you're fitting it
it's fitting you know you're
approximating this one hundred thousand
hundred thousand matrix by some screener
dimensional matrix okay that's the SPD
singular value decomposition and that
turns out to be a good fit and the
question is what property of language
causes this 100 thousand hundred
thousand matrix to have approximate rank
300 right so describe some plausible
somatic process which leads to this
problem right so that could be something
theory can do and then of course we'll
see if having a theoretical more
gives you some new insight which the
these people didn't have okay so the
main issue here as I pointed out earlier
is the non-linearity on the logarithm
okay so for instance if you didn't have
the log then there's a existing
explanation which is topic models which
I won't describe here but those of you
have seen it turns out this reasonable
explanation for Corcoran's counts being
low dimensional but this is a log of the
quadrants
okay so in this paper we this which
appeared and tackle this summer this is
a journal in competition linguistics
actually it has very interesting
publication model if anybody wants talk
to me about it so it's so what we have
here is what we think of as a dynamic
version of a log linear topic model also
this was proposed by me and Hinton same
person who did the RBM around the same
time and let me describe to you so
there's a semantic space inside the
writers head and each direction in and
that's its d dimensional and each
direction in the dimensions is
associated with a discourse which is
some narrow topic ok so you might be
talking about hunting and then you may
be talking about lines and tigers or
something ok now as this hypothetical
writer or set of writers generate
Wikipedia we are assuming that oh sorry
the other thing I hold we say that each
word all W also is associated with the
vector V W in this little space ok
and as this writer or set of writers
generate Wikipedia we say that the core
we imagine that the corpus was generated
by doing a random walk on the sphere of
this discourse vector C ok and the
process of outputting words is that the
probability that the words output when
the discourse is CT is proportional to
the exponential of VW and CT
so what is the property of this
distribution so CT is a direction in
space and it's moving around and as it
moves around it generates the
distribution on words and each step the
words that are output are those that are
likely to be that I actually have high
in a product
okay that's moving around so of course
words that are close to each other right
would tend to have high inner product
with the same cities so they tend to
co-occur right intuitively this has that
probably in traditional topic models you
would not have had this exponential we
would not have the exponential correct
yeah yeah so Robbie's comment was that
if you take away the exponential this
would be more like a normal Top Model
okay so now any questions about this one
uniform renoir yeah we're assuming that
okay
geometric random or so right so within a
document you know the what's being
talked about drifts a little bit right
and then in the next document it might
make a big jump so big jumps are allowed
and that doesn't change the distribution
much questions okay so the question is
what is yeah what distribution on
diagrams oh sorry diagrams is you know
pairs of words occurring close to each
other
what distribution on pairs of words does
this process generally write and does it
have that property that that you know
that the PMI matrix that we saw in the
previous slide has low rank and aside is
that this is very reminiscent of RBM of
course this mole comes from Hinton again
Hinton just had a static model and we
have a random walk here but it's very
reminiscent and yeah this was a phase
and Hinton's life where he was very
interested in these log linear models
okay so that's where our BM and this
both come from so this is just an
illustration there's nothing much here
for the theory audience that except it's
depicting a random walk and the random
walk is just depicting there's a real
English paragraph that's going through
and you knew who's here just fitted a
random walk to it okay using the world
vectors that we train so if you want to
know how this was fitted ask me later
but yeah that's the just showing you a
random walk that's happening as you go
through this paragraph
so we're inferring this backwards
induction backwards inference we've
already learned the word vectors and so
on and we are inferring the random walk
that must have led to this paragraph
questions yeah it's there's a
statistical procedure to do it but I
won't go into the details as I said if
you can ask me this was still as an
escalation okay that there's a random
walk and it's generating words emitting
words and how did I get that random walk
and it was because then you fitted a
random walk to actual text so what you
can do CT the discourse vector we call
it a discourse back yeah it's sort of
what's being talked about right now oh
you mean that figure yeah it's something
like that yeah okay so how do we analyze
this okay so you have to integrate out
the random walk right so you are just
observing words you don't know what the
random walk was and the distribution
that you're seeing is you know the
integration with the random walk right
because the huge long random walk took
place and the words appear and you saw
the empirical distribution and now
you're trying to see what that
distribution should be like so a key
assumption in our proof is a special
isotropy of word vectors this was a new
discovery which we thought had to be
true if things like this work and then
we measure it and it is actually purely
actual topic so that is in the bulk the
word vectors behave like a set of random
vectors okay so like scale gaussians and
so a consequence is that if you have any
sort of word vectors through neuron in
space like this then when you do a
random walk then for most directions
this partition function zc which is a
sum over w of exponential VW times C is
approximately constant okay so this can
be proven under that assumption and it's
actually empirically true so we find
word vectors and then we tested this and
it's actually pretty true
okay so we did we came up with this just
purely from theory because that's the
only way the theory could possibly work
like the integration could work and then
we went back and saw that actually in
NLP in the last years ago people had
notice this that you can just ignore
this partition function it stays
constant it's called self normalization
for these probabilistic models and
people had studied it okay so we sort of
stumbled upon a fact that people hadn't
particularly found that ignore the
partition function treated as a constant
and it was okay right right right so it
really it can only work in low
dimensions this fact can only work no
dimensions correct there's actually
another place in the theory world low
dimensions used I'll see if I get to it
so so then if you make that assumption
the integration works are well and what
you can show that under this assumptions
right which already set the score space
CT is doing a random walk and the word
back to the specialized atrophic I can
show we can show that the main theorem
is that this PMI count for any pair of
words is equal to the inner product is
purple it's very really related to the
inner product of the corresponding word
juice okay so the word vectors are the
latent variables in this model it's a
probabilistic model and in a product of
those word vectors is after scaling the
PMI okay so it explains why this PMI
matrix is low rank
okay these low dimensional vectors
actually they're inner products
correspond to the PMI that the log of
the probability is VW square and so the
norm of the word vector determines the
frequency and the spatial orientation
like the inner product determine the
meaning right because the PMI values of
all the other words they tell me the
meaning of word up that's okay and this
actually fits within 17 percent entry
wise on average so it answers question 1
actually we came up with a different
objective which fits somewhat better
than this but I wasn't going to back any
questions I mean I know if you're the
place the exponential if I saw the
function the Lord would be a place sort
of by its inverse or no the log
interacts very very intimately with with
the sphere right the sphere is like
Gaussian so I'm not sure if any function
would work yeah any questions
okay so they're having embedding methods
so how am i doing on time oh okay so
previous nonlin it turns out previous
nonlinear embedding methods like word to
back which I mentioned and glove which
is a stanford version approximation is a
max that give it fit to our model okay
so i want i just quickly go over it you
know if you look at the expressions they
are kind of including the glove
expression which is sorry the word to
expression that i mentioned earlier
these turned out to be like max
likelihood bit okay one theory question
here that arises if you actually look at
this fitting objective that it's not SVD
it's weighted SVD weighted SVD is this
objective that you are you're given a
matrix a and you're trying to find the
rank K matrix X that minimizes you know
the this l2 difference but there's a
weighting W IJ so this weighting matrix
W IJ Y makes this weighted s-video and
makes it np-hard so so that's our
training objective it can be solved in
practice like many machine learning
problems by just gradient descent plus
regularizer Caldera grad and some of my
students have been working on their
iving provable polynomial time Aaron for
it for this and they made some progress
when W is random like okay these numbers
show them so Fran I'm like then you can
actually solve this who would be okay
next question why do relations
correspond to directions remember Queen
is equal to King - man plus woman right
this kind of facts wider wider word
vectors solve analogies and actually
there was some controversy about it you
know because anecdotal counter examples
can be found do that so we sort of
exploded a little bit more both
empirically and theoretically and what
we do with our theory is to get
theoretical support for the following
that for every relation R so in this
case relation would be like male female
masculine feminine the difference
vectors of these align according to some
direction which depends on the relation
so this can be proven okay
yeah so so you know this is what's
formalizing what is the relation that
actually existed in previous paper by
Pennington around and the idea is that
you know this masculine feminine
relation what does it mean it's relation
it means that for other words Chi the
probability that they occur in the
neighborhood of King and in the neighbor
of Queen that ratio is equal to you know
for all other masculine feminine in
Paris this the ratio of the
probabilities okay so it so that's a
reasonable definition of relation
because it cries unrelated or gender
right then both sides are one right the
like walking or talking gonna relate to
gender but if it's like grass or John
which are very gender specific then
these probabilities deviate from one in
the same direction okay so so you can
formalize this as saying that a and B
satisfies this relation if this log of
this is something like some constant
depending on the relation plus noise
okay this you cannot verify in
particular you know it's not enough
samples but what our model implies is
that for such a relation are there exist
directions such that this is this
happens okay what I claim that the
difference vector for the words in this
relation a minus B corresponds to some
Direction plus smaller noise and this
noise is smaller than what was over here
so this you can verify this we verify so
we verified it using lots of I mentioned
before there are lots of relations or
there are available online freebase and
so on and this is true okay and actually
this noise does behave just like
Gaussian
okay another paper polysemy onward back
there so so far I I was just saying this
theory theory explains empirically the
things that people are doing but now
here's something that was not known and
there was a new discovery from our
theory
suppose I mean you know Sir Ward vectors
how do they contain the various meanings
of the word okay because words have
multiple meanings so and it's called
polysemy so the word thai can mean the
article of clothing or a physical act
okay so how does the word vector for
thai contain those two means so we
thought about it and we said okay let's
think of the following thought
experiment that tie is really towards
Taiwan and tie two which happened to be
represented by the same letters T ie so
then you can try the following thought
experiment but you can do it in practice
so suppose this means that there were
two words Taiwan and tie two and they
were unrelated words and they were put
together in the same word so you can try
this synthetically okay so take to a
random unrelated W in W 2 but one is
much more frequent than the other and
declare these to be a single new word
and compute its embedding in the model
so you have the embeddings of the old
words and you're the embedding of the
new work and how it is the new embedding
compared to the old embedding and the
answer is it's something like a linear
combination okay
the amazing method is crazy nonlinear
logs and so on but it B is linearly like
this and this we can also explain
mathematically no model and turns out
that our explanation then leads to a way
to extract the different meanings
rushing through this I'm out of time but
it's something called sparse coding
which is a another np-hard thing which
you can do in practice and we can get
you know meanings out so for instance
these are the meanings for Thai so this
is like the clothing meaning this is
like Thai the like game this is like a
scoreless game or tied game score let's
go less equal Iser this is like tying up
things wires cables etc and this is
opera which I think might be junk but
some people say I mean Thai is an
important word in Opera so maybe it's
not
okay so the point is this was a new
discovery
okay people had always wondered how do
how does polysemy effect word embeddings
and this was the clean answer and I want
to finish with sentence embeddings this
is a very new manuscript which is a some
upcoming nips bookshop so its sentence
embeddings okay so remember these are
computed using recurrent neural Nets and
so on so we give a very simple sentence
embeddings which I'll describe okay and
it's inspired by this work of weeding it
out which was simple where the sentence
embedding was just the average of the
warden biddings in the sentence which
they show works sort of okay although
they're short other ways to improve it
but that was already there and that
seemed very reminiscent of our theory so
we explore it some more and then we
realize that actually the correct so
this took some playing around but the
correct model we think is the following
that earlier I told you this model where
where I didn't have this term but we now
think that this is actually the correct
model the probability W is output is a
combination of two things so this is the
old probability okay the discourse and
so on and the first mode is just a
background probability so everywhere is
a background probability and it just
gets emitted okay so for instance even
though you're going to be talking about
jungle and which means you talk about
lions and tigers and so on but maybe
somebody was eating a cake in the jungle
right so that's like a background
probability of cake and that can also be
emitted okay so there's our simple model
and then you analyze this and so now the
so some sentence was generated using
this model and you know the word vectors
okay you've estimated those again by the
model so now what's the math like the
rest of the sentence vector it's a so
this CT turns out is a weighted sum of
the word vectors okay in this sentence
and this weighting is some of this B sub
beta sub W is awaiting so it's a
weighted sum of the word vectors in the
sentence and this weighting is something
like a over a plus P WPW is the
background probability so all of those
you can estimate and that actually does
really well this embedding okay so this
is a completely avoids method for
sentence embedding
right just trained this method on
Wikipedia it really beats like some
pretty highly tuned neural nets that
people have come away including skip
taught and some standard thoughts and
some standard tasks yeah and also this
waiting the exploits when they see it
they're reminded of TF idea so this is a
heuristic from information retrieval
that you in any context when you're
looking at words you weight the words
according to some heuristic called TF
idea it's very reminiscent of that but
in this context there's really no
explanation why you should ever want to
wait the word but it's a simple
explanation of the small okay so I'll
conclude by summarizing okay so you can
do a theory that explains and addresses
behavior seemingly intractable models
okay that we've been scared of such as
our names and our beams the empirical
results are good out of just it's a
theoretical model but you can solve it
and you get sentence embeddings word
embeddings our sentence embedding is the
best purely so unsupervised and betting
we know okay better than the neural net
yeah it's completely transparent okay
you understand exactly where it's coming
from and there's some unpublished work
maybe I'll talk about it in the quick
talks later at this time you can use
these sentence embeddings to understand
fMRI right so fMRI data from the brain
they do blood flow measurements you want
to understand those if I yeah if there's
time in the afternoon I can give we've
talked about it yeah and finally the
message that I've been urging on all my
friends is that we have to embrace this
new age of algorithms you know it's not
about you know graphs and clicks or
flows or whatever you know it's all this
kind of data and this is largely being
driven by experimental discoveries as
you could see in this talk but I think
there's interesting theory to be done
and new models to be created and so on
thank you how did your sentence abetik
do on those initial sentences what did
it say about those in full sentences
issues those examples that you get oh
yeah well I actually came with a
sentence only last night but I'm pretty
sure that it'll be it'll do the right
thing I mean we've been testing it yeah
I mean I can see at a glance that it'll
pretty well yeah importance so it's just
this is important it's a random walk
isn't something you could imagine that
you know a speaker who's trying to make
a point you know it's somehow trying to
get the reader from one state to another
state they're doing some sort of walk
it's directed in some way or whatever
yeah so yeah so I think and yeah the
question is it is really a random walk
like uniform in the sphere I think
because Wikipedia has you know hundreds
and thousands of writers it does look
kind of random if you would have fit it
to Shakespeare or something probably it
would not look so random so notice that
this is random it looks random in the
aggregate right you take the entire
Wikipedia of course any particular
article in there is written in a certain
voice and what we are with a certain
vocabulary and so locally it's not
random definitely and yeah people have
yeah we've been we've been looking at
that kind of analysis to using some of
our more sophisticated models with some
colleagues were
these predictions they according to your
models to predictions that you do when
you know who the speaker the writer is
allowables we better to have yeah to fit
a model to the writer yeah but you so
this is an aggregate model right the
random walk right so you could to do it
we're doing it with some social
scientist who is interested in analyzing
text so he's talking to us we have to do
something else I mean you can treat it
just as a random walk so yeah so you
have to do some tweaks to understand
specific text blogs or something
yeah
so yeah that's that's actually an easy
trick yeah yeah no I'm saying that's a
different thing yeah that's the question
was you know there's this work which is
some kind of a signature of the writer
right which is an easier trick I think
that you can just see what they work at
the reuse or something what words
they'll use predict right according the
writer yes you can do that the same
thing so I think those are using topic
models yeah that's a much more developed
view
so Shakespeare's work vectors will love
the uniform right